[Aplausos]
esta noche les voy a contar
la historia
de mi striptease editorial la historia
en la que salí intelectual y
periodísticamente en pelotas ante el
país y como lo sigo haciendo la forma en
que realizo mi trabajo ha generado
muchísimos aplausos muchísimos
seguidores también he sido imperceptible
y como una mosca cualquiera para
muchísima gente y también he logrado que
muchísima gente me odie en cantidades
industriales incluso quería preguntar y
que alcen la mano quienes saben lo que
yo hago a lenka visto algo de mi trabajo
chévere a quienes les gusta lo que hago
y al ser la mano de los que me odian
a ver si hay
excelente yo lo sabemos en cambio
cuando inicié mi carrera
de periodismo me dijeron que tenía que
ser un niño bueno que tenía que ser como
todos los periodistas habían sido
durante los últimos 100 años que tenía
que dejar de ser un hippie que tenía que
bañarme aunque si me bañaba que tenía
que vestirme mejor y tenía que
convertirme en este periodista impoluto
perfecto y tenía que ponerme gel mucho
gel y efectivamente fue lo que hice me
vestí bien y fui a trabajar en la
redacción de los diarios tradicionales
importantes de este país y buscaba
siempre cumplir a cabalidad los
principios deontológicos de los padres
fundadores del periodismo mundial
lo hacía relativamente bien
qué sucedió me convertí en un periodista
como todos los que ya habían pasado por
este país
y que básicamente lo que hacía a través
de un periódico o de una radio o de una
televisora era advertir sobre el pueblo
ignorante una verdad para iluminarlos
desde él desde el trono del periodismo
que lo sabe todo y yo en realidad
esto de ser objetivo esto de ser
imparcial estas cosas que nos dicen que
tenemos que cumplir los periodistas
obligatoriamente como que no me cuadraba
y revise qué quiere decir
esta onda de ser objetivo no y dice
perteneciente o relativo al objeto y yo
así mi objeto sexual ha llegado peor a
objeto cualquiera y la segunda
definición decía desinteresado
y desapasionado lo cual me escandalizaba
porque soy una persona con intereses y
aquí pueden cortar el vídeo y decir mira
el banco tiene intereses de la silla de
la banca de la derecha y no pero tengo
intereses tengo interés de hacer un
periodismo más fresco tengo interés de
hacer un periodismo más irreverente
tengo interés de tener una sociedad más
democrática tengo interés de tener una
sociedad mejor informada tengo varios
intereses
y la otra es desapasionado y si es que
tengo que obligatoriamente hacer mi
trabajo sin pasión pues esta cosa no va
para adelante
entonces yo en la oficina era así me
ponía mi corbata como les contaba pero
yo en la noche era así
[Música]
yo no quiero decir de que pretendo dar
las noticias con unos globos inflados
que en forma de senos aún y pero lo que
yo me preguntaba es cómo puedo yo
traducir mi personalidad hacia mi
carrera o sea cómo puedo ser la misma
persona y no tener que construir un
prototipo para ir cada mañana a trabajar
ya entrevistar a las personas muy
seriamente y utilizando palabras
rebuscadas y además estaba en un
contexto de la década pasada en la que
el gobierno y la legislación perseguían
a cualquier periodista que trataba de
expresar algo diferente o que trataba de
exteriorizar su opinión sobre las cosas
entonces en ese contexto dije [ __ ] y
ahora qué hago yo a ver por qué no me
presento en internet y en vivo donde hay
más libertad y que sabes hacer soy un
pésimo cantante soy un pésimo bailarín
soy un pésimo guitarrista lo que sé
hacer es entrevistar entonces dije el
país está saturado de la entrevista
típica perfecta
en la mañana entrevistan al político que
va ensayando toda la noche que va a
decir al día siguiente y dicen cosas
perfectas cultivado por un consultor
político para que diga perfectamente eso
y yo dije al [ __ ] con eso y nació esto
para empezar a hablar
[Música]
si el lunes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
[Risas]
yo dije en ese contexto de falta de
libertades yo dije el país necesita un
espacio donde primero reírse donde
hablar libremente donde conversar sobre
las cosas importantes de este país sin
aburrirnos en el que el reto más
importante de todo este proyecto era que
a la gente le dé ganas de tomarse un
vino mientras hablamos del producto
interno bruto y como logro eso pues
entrevistando como soy yo en realidad
claro los grandes teóricos de la
comunicación decían jesús que está
haciendo el vivanco aquí ahora se
descarrió el muchacho verde una mala
palabra hasta se tomó un vino dos tres y
hasta medio rojito
como puede hacer eso y romper lo normal
del periodismo y yo decía [ __ ] pero a
mí me parece un ejercicio más
periodístico esto porque estamos viendo
al entrevistado como es en realidad y
haciéndole las preguntas que no se
atreve nadie hace dos me parece mucho
más transparente y cuando empecé y
parecía que todo iba a ir así
porque después de la primera después de
la primera experiencia que hubo bastante
público porque se hace con público en
vivo luego de la primera experiencia
empezó a disminuir la cantidad de gente
entonces llegó un momento en el que
estaban mis viejos mi novia en ese
tiempo digo en ese tiempo porque eres mi
esposa
y este mi mejor amigo que nunca falla
y entonces dije bueno esta pendejada ya
no valió en realidad los teóricos de la
comunicación tenían razón yo que estoy
haciendo pendejadas
de ghana
pero al poco tiempo empezó a suceder
esto sapo altamente evolucionado cuenta
la historia de la cárcel cuando te
enamoraste
te has pensado como un empleado no es
pesado es claro
yo soy almería y cuantas cosas
sólo muestra que tú nos pediste la
información a torito y los teóricos de
la comunicación nos deja medio
desbaratado pero ya se están yendo de
pueblo que está por algo más
el público estaba necesitado de un
espacio libre también rompía el el
supuesto de que la gente no ve cosas
largas en internet las entrevistas más
vistas son todas estas de más de una
hora y media en internet y la gente la
consume la exige y la comparte y ahí es
cuando yo digo en realidad esos
conceptos para mí se tienen que ir al
[ __ ] porque porque uno no es imparcial
como periodista y no debe ser imparcial
porque porque uno es un ser humano y uno
tiene una forma de ver el mundo
yo tengo raíces loja no es lo que me
hace lojano
soy hincha de la liga que por cierto hoy
clasificó a la final
y uno tiene esa construcción mental con
esa construcción mental es que uno
relata y conduce y da testimonio de los
hechos una cosa es de que jamás voy a
torcer los datos a conveniencia ni voy a
manipular la verdad a conveniencia pero
sí que sepan como un ejercicio de
sinceridad editorial desde que el lado
del mundo estoy yo viendo las cosas y me
parece mucho más honesto con mis
audiencias que digan el banco dice datos
certeros pero esa es la mentalidad del
banco y desde ese lado lo está diciendo
pero en este país no quieren que seamos
monjes tibetanos que no queremos no
vemos nos sentimos que no somos hinchas
del quito
pero no es así y es un ejercicio como yo
le llamo de sinceridad editorial
y con el tiempo yo estaba haciendo las
entrevistas en la noche y en el día
seguía siendo este bruno díaz y era
batman en las noches y dije como diablos
puedo ser completamente yo y hacer de
esto mi carrera mi profesión mi marca
personal y al que le guste bien y al que
no también y además se creó esta
audiencia tan heterogénea en la que voy
a dar charlas en un colegio o en una
universidad y los jóvenes me dicen la
única forma que tengo para enterarme de
la política de este país es a través de
tus programas
señores y señoras de más de 70 años este
que también no se pierden un zoólogo de
este programa y esto de mayores de 70
años le encanta mi esposa porque mi club
de fans de mujeres tienen todas más de
70 años
y
y eso al final del día es el objetivo
porque el objetivo es traer este gran
debate público este gran debate que la
gente no llega a enterarse y traerlo a
la gente sencilla a nosotros a la gente
normal porque porque la gente normal
necesita estar informada y porque porque
esta gente normal al estar informada
toma mejores decisiones al final del día
y mejores decisiones cada cuatro años
cuando se presenta ante una urna
electoral entonces es muy importante
de codificar el producto interno bruto
la deuda externa y la política para
traerla a la gente normal entonces en
esta gran duda dije cómo hago mi gran
destape y me encontré con otro loco que
es mi socio que es anderson buscan que
es tan tacaño que no pago para venir hoy
y él venía también de una carrera
bastante exitosa en otro periódico de la
ciudad de guayaquil
y en una reunión que tuvimos me dijo
exactamente lo mismo que yo pensaba ya
estoy harto del periodismo convencional
me parece que tenemos que creer que este
país necesita con urgencia una
plataforma una plataforma de periodismo
irreverente fresco ignacio a la posta y
fue tanto el gran destape que incluso
esta imagen que ustedes están viendo a
través es una imagen real la imagen de
promoción del lanzamiento de la posta y
colgamos unos carteles grandotes con
nuestros cuerpos desnudos y los hacíamos
volar en drones por la ciudad en medio
de los autos y los teóricos de la
comunicación decían jesús este muchacho
ahora ya sale hasta en pelotas
dios mío eso no es periodismo
y nosotros en cambio creemos que
mientras más transparentes seamos desde
nuestras opiniones y de nuestra posición
ante el mundo y ante el país de ante los
hechos mejor periodismo podemos hacer y
por eso es que ahora hacemos cosas como
estas en las que tenemos mucho más
impacto que tal vez cualquier noticia
que puede salir en un periódico
tradicional hola queridos amigos ya se
nos acabó este delicioso cambio con sana
valoración y no se acaba la sesión hola
queridos amigos estamos aquí adivinen
donde adivina en donde hemos venido a
ver el elefante blanco más moderno de
sudamérica con nosotros tienen la
costumbre de la posta le hemos traído
para el árbol sitio y la merienda al
señor carlos ochoa
ya que se ha quedado sin camello
aquí les dejo mis cinco para lo que
queremos la mayoría de demostración
yo creo que hoy más que nada el pellejo
que se está jugando
es el del mote pillo
o sea mayor
yo la voy a visitar no se preocupen la
casilla celebrando con nosotros su
despedida por el hecho de que hemos
gastado 60 millones de dólares en este
edificio entonces nos están prohibiendo
poderles mostrar este edificio en el que
básicamente a ti te habrá tocado por 60
millones todos habremos puesto no siendo
agrade
sí sí estoy diciendo que no voy a entrar
vamos ya abrimos una botella de champán
al frente de la cancillería hablamos
sobre política exterior ecuatoriana y
celebramos la vida de la canciller este
feliz mente y hablamos sobre eso sobre
este tema vamos y hacemos una
transmisión a llamar el elefante blanco
un edificio que es un elefante blanco y
lo hacemos de frente la gente lo
comparte la gente entiende sobre la
problemática que estamos hablando y en
realidad yo no creo yo no digo que lo
que yo haga es lo que tiene que hacer sí
que todos terminemos en pelotas en el
periodismo ecuatoriano y no creo no se
verá digo que no en pelotas no estoy
seguro de eso
pero dijo que habla así del corazón
y bueno
yo no estoy diciendo que todos tienen
que hacer esto yo respeto y admiro a
todos mis otros colegas que hacen el
periodismo tradicional son valientes
hacen su trabajo todos los días es muy
importante yo lo que digo es de que el
país a mi modo de ver necesitaba
otra opción de periodismo un poco más
juvenil y hervir
irreverente y yo no quiero volver a
hacer el periodismo serio y tampoco
quiero que me amen pero si es que me
llaman yo también los voy a amar
y tampoco quiero que me odien y si es
que me odian igual los voy a amar
y si es que soy insignificante y no
existo pues es lo que sucede pero si es
que yo no puedo mantenerme en este
striptease editorial y hacer algo más
fresco y divertirme todos los días que
vaya a trabajar pues tendré que pensar
en dedicarme al striptease convencional
y trabajar en despedidas de solteras
pero yo creo que con esta panza
no me iría tan bien muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]